so we've been discussing graph limits
for a couple lectures now in the first
lecture on graph limits so two lectures
ago I stated a number of main theorems
and today we will prove these theorems
using some of the tools that we
developed last time namely the
regularity lemma and also we proved this
martingale convergence theorem which
will also come in okay so let me recall
what were the three main theorems that
we stated at the end of two lectures ago
so one of them was the equivalence of
convergence on one hand we defined a
notion of convergence where we say that
W n approaches W by definition if the F
densities converge we can say
convergence even without a limit in mind
where we say a sequence converges if all
of these F densities converge so the
first main theorem was that the two
notions of equal convergence are
equivalent so one notion being
convergence in terms of f densities and
the second ocean being convergence in
the sense of the cut norm the cut
distance there was a second theorem that
tells us that limits always exist you
can if you have a convergent sequence
then you can represent a limit by a
graph on and the third statement was
about compactness of the space of
griffons okay so we're actually going to
prove these theorems in Reverse water
we're going to start with the
compactness and work backwards okay so
this is not how these terms were
originally proved we're not in that
water but it will be helpful to for us
to do this by first considering the
compactness statement so remember what
compactness says I start with this space
w total which is the space of graphics
where I identify griffons that have
distance zero so if they have cut
distance 0 than I refer to them as the
same point so this is now a metric space
and the theorem is that this space is
compact so I think this it's a really
nice term it's a beautiful theorem that
encapsulates a lot of what we've been
talking about so far with similarities
regularity and whatnot in a
qualitatively succinctly
just that this space of graphing is
compact you may not have some intuition
about what the space looks like at the
moment I mean I will see the proof and
hopefully that will give you some more
intuition I first learned about this
theorem when last all of us who was one
of the pioneers in the subject when he
came to MIT to give a talk when I was a
graduate student and he said that you
know analysts thought that they pretty
much knew all the naturally-occurring
compact spaces out there so there are
lots of spaces that occurring analysis
in topology that are compact I'm the
first one you learn in analysis
undergraduate it's probably that an
interval which is compact but there are
also many other spaces but this one here
doesn't seem to be any of these
classical notions of compactness right
so it's in some sense a new compact
space so so let's see how the proof goes
now because we're working in a metric
space it suffices to show due to the
equivalence between compactness in a
sense of finite open covers and
sequential compactness in a metric space
suffice us to show sequential
compactness that every sequence has a
convergent subsequence cut metric and
also will produce a limit as a
convergent subsequence so that's what we
do I give you an arbitrary sequence of
griffons I want to construct by taking
sub sequences a convergent sequence and
I will tell you what that limit is so
here's what we're going to do given the
sequence as I hinted before it has to do
with the regularity lemma so we're going
to apply the regularity lemma in the
above form which we did last time so
apply the weak regularity lemma which
will tell us that for each WM there
exists a partition in fact a sequence of
partitions each one refining the next so
what's going to happen is I'm going to
start with WN and starting with the
trivial part
apply that lemma and obtain a partition
P sub n comma 1 and then starting with
that as now P naught I'm going to apply
regularity lemma again and obtain a
refinement okay I will have this
sequence of partitions each one refining
the next so all these are going to be
partitions of the zero one interval and
as I mentioned last time everything's
going to be measurable I'm not going to
even mention measurability everything
will be measurable such that they
satisfy the following conditions ok so
the first one is what I mentioned
further earlier is that you have a
sequence of refinements so each P sub
and k plus 1 refines the previous one so
for all and then K in the second
condition is given by the regularity
lemma you get to control the number of
parts so say in the third part what the
error of approximation is but you got to
control the number of parts so in
particular I can make sure that this
number here the number of parts in the
cave partition depends only on K
now you might complain somewhat because
the regularity lemma only tells you an
upper bound on the number of parts but
that's okay I can add I can allow empty
parts so now I make sure that the cave
partition has exactly n K parts and the
third one has to do with the error of
approximation so now setting okay so
suppose we writing suppose we write W
sub n K as the graph on obtained by
applying the stepping operator so this
is the averaging operator on this
partition the corresponding to the K
partition I apply that partition do a
stepping a virgin operator on the nth
graph on I get W sub NK the third
condition is that the cave partition
approximates it's a good approximation
in the cut norm up to error 1 over K so
1 over K is some arbitrary sequence
going to 0 as K goes to infinity
[Applause]
so I obtained the sequence of partitions
so by applying the regularity lemma two
to each to each graph on in the sequence
now these croissants I mean they each
had their own vertex set and so far
they're now related to each other but to
make the visualization easier and also
to in order to do the next step in the
proof I'm going to do some major
preserving bisection so think of this as
permuting the vertex labels some so
initially you might have a partition
into arbitrary measurable sets what I
can do is push over the first set to the
left and so on so do a major preserving
back section by injection in a way so
that I can maintain that all the
partitions are visually chopping up into
intervals
okay the question is it may be the case
that for a given K I can do this
arrangement but it's not clear to you at
the moment why you can do this uniformly
for all K so one way to get around this
is for now just think of for each given
K and then you'll see at the end that
that's already enough okay any more
questions so so now assume all of these
P sub K and K are intervals so in fact
you know what you said maybe a better
way to go but to make our life a little
bit easier let's just assume for now
that you can't do this okay and what's
going to happen next is some kind of a
diagonalization argument we're going to
be picking sub sequences so I'm going to
be picking sub sequences so that they
are going to have very nice convergence
properties and so I'm going to
repeatedly throw out a lot of the
sequence so this is a diagnol ization
argument and basically what happens is
that by passing two sub sequences and
we're going to do this repeatedly many
times we can assume first that the
endpoints P sub and 1 they converge and
goes to infinity so each piece up and 1
is some partition
into of interval right into some bound
some fixed number of parts so by passing
to a subsequence I make sure that the
division points all converge okay and
now by passing one more time
okay so by passing two subsequence one
more time let's assume that also W sub
and one converges to some function some
graph on you one point wise so initially
I have these graph ons each one of them
is a M by M block they have various
division points by passing to a
subsequence I assume that the point of
division they converge and now by
passing to an additional subsequence I
can make sure the individual values they
converge so as a result W sub n comma
one converges to W one converges to some
graph on you one point wise almost
everywhere and we repeat for W sub n K
for each K okay so do this sequentially
so we just did it for K equals to one
now do it for two three four and so on
so this is a diagonalization argument we
do this countably many times at the end
what do we get
passed down to the following subsequence
and just to make my life a bit more
convenient instead of labeling the
vertices of the subject
labeling the indices of the subsequence
I'm going to real Abel the sequence so
that it's still labeled I 1 2 3 4 and so
on
so we now pass to a sequence W 1 2 3 and
so on such that if you look at the first
partition the first week regularity
partition they produce W 1 1 W 1 and so
on and these guys they converge to you
one point wise ok the second level W 2 1
w w1 q w1 w2 w3 2 they converge to you
two point wise and so on okay so far so
good question
so why if there's a question is why is
this true why I stopped us
w and comma one converge to W 1 W
converts to u 1 pointless initially am I
not but what I'm saying is you can pass
to subsequence you can pass the
subsequent because there are only M 1
parts so it's an M by M 1 by M 1 matrix
of real numbers and only have finally
found the menu of them so you can pick a
subsequence so that they converge yeah
okay so you're asking if we do this
slightly not so carefully we might end
up with an empty sequence all right so
this is why I say you have to do a
diagonal ization argument each step you
keep the first term the sequence so that
you always maintain some sequence so you
can you have to be slightly careful what
diagonalization
okay any more questions all right
so by passing to a subsequence we obtain
this very nice sequence that's nice
subsequence such that each row
corresponding to each level of
regularization converges point-wise to
some you so what do these use look like
so they are step griffons so let's
explore the structure of you a bit more
okay so since we have that each okay so
we have the property that each partition
refines the previous partition and as a
result if you look at the K plus 1
stepping and I step it by the previous
partition in the sequence I should get
back
I should call back one in the sequence
so this was the this graph on obtained
by averaging over the Kate partition and
this is the graph on obtained by
averaging the over the k plus first
partition so if I go back one more I
should go back in the sequence and since
use the use are the point wise limit of
these double use the same relationship
should also hold for the use namely that
u sub K should equal to u sub P a u sub
K plus 1 if I step it with PK where PK
is the okay so if you look at all these
endpoints converge and these partitions
they converge to p1 ok so if you look at
the partitions that correspond to P 1 P
2 1 and so on
I want these partitions to converge to P
1 I want these partitions
to convert you teach you
so all these partitions there there are
partitions into intervals so I'm just
saying if you look at where the
intervals were the divisions of
intervals go they converge and I'm
calling the limit partition P sub K and
here we're using that P sub K plus 1
refines P sub K because the same is true
for each end so in the limit the same
must be true as well okay so you have
this column of use so let me draw you a
picture of what this use could look like
alright so here's an illustration that
may be helpful
so what could these use look like each
one of them is represented by values on
the unit square and I write this in
matrix notation so that the origin is at
the top left corner so you one might be
well maybe P one is just the trivial
partition in which case u 1 is going to
be a constant graph um let's say it has
value point 5 u 2 came from u 1 by some
partitioning suppose just for the sake
of illustration there was only a
partitioning into two parts and okay so
it doesn't have to be I think Warren it
doesn't have to be at midpoint but just
for illustration suppose the division
were at the midpoint because you one
needs to have okay so this point five
value should be the average value in all
of these four squares so for instance
the points maybe like 0.6 0.6 0.4
so for example and in u3 the
partitioning the p3 partition so here
the partitions p1 partition is p2 that's
two parts and suppose p3 now has four
parts and again for illustration sake
suppose it is equally dividing the
interval into four intervals it could be
that now each of these parts is split up
into four different values in a way that
so you can obtain the original numbers
by averaging so that's one possible
example likewise you can have something
like that
so and I should maintain symmetry in
this matrix and last why I'm just gonna
be lazy and say that it's still 0.4
throughout okay so this is what the
sequence of views are going to look like
each one of them split up a box in the
previous view in such way that the local
averages the step averages are preserved
any questions so far all right so now we
get to martingales so I claim that this
is basically a martingale okay so in
suppose you let XY be a uniform point in
the unit square and consider this
sequence so this is now a random
sequence because XY are random I
evaluate this use on this random uniform
random point X comma Y so this is a
random sequence and the main observation
is that this is a marking
so remember the definition of a
martingale for last time martingale is
one where if you look at the value of U
sub K conditioned on the previous values
the expectation is just the previous
term and I claim this as true for the
sequence because of the way we
constructed it it's splitting up each
box in an averaging preserving way a
different way to see this and for those
of you who actually know what the
definition of a random variable is in
the probability theory is that you
should do this zero one squared as the
probability space in which case you
itself is the random variable and this
partitioning gives you a filtration of
the space it's a sequence of Sigma
algebra dividing up the space into finer
and finer pieces so this is really what
a martingale is what we have a
martingale it's bounded because the
values take place in 0 1 so by the
martingale convergence theorem which we
proved last time we find that the
sequence must converge to some limit so
so this is the sequence of martingale
converges which means by interpretation
so there exists ru which is a graph on
such that U K converges to u point-wise
almost everywhere as K goes to infinity
that's the limit ok so this is this is a
limit and we're going to show that it
has indeed a limit but you see this is a
construction of the limit where we took
regularity got all these nice pieces
founds convergent subsequences and then
apply the martingale convergence
sequence of martingale convergence
theorem to produce for us this candidate
for the limit this u so now let us show
that it is indeed the limit that we're
looking for in that in the subsequence
so again have passed out all the terms
which we removed from in passing two sub
sequences so in the remaining
subsequence I want to show that the W
ends indeed converge to U and this is
now a fairly straightforward three
Absalom's argument a standard analysis
argument but look a so let's carry it
through so for every epsilon bigger than
zero
suppose you pick a sufficiently large
okay so there exists a sufficiently
large cake make sure K is large enough
such that U differs from okay l1 norm at
most epsilon over 3 because the you case
they converge to you point wise almost
everywhere okay so we find this case so
let's fix escape then there exists and
not such that if you look at this u sub
K it does not it is very close to W sub
and K for all and large enough
so because our farm because of what
happened up there so we can now compute
the difference between fact let's do it
this way
so now let's compute difference cut norm
of the difference between the term in
the sequence W sub N and you triangle
inequality we have following it's true
okay
the cut norm is upper bounded by the l1
norm look at the definitions replace the
first couple of these the first term I
claim is at most epsilon over 3
the second term is going to be at least
epsilon over 3 and the third term is
going to be also at most epsilon over 3
because well from the regularity
approximation I know that it is at most
1 over K and I chose K large enough so
that is also at most epsilon over 3 put
everything together we find that these
two are they differ by most epsilon if n
is large enough but now since epsilon
can be arbitrarily small we find that
you indeed have convergence as cleaned
and this finish is the proof of
compactness so there are a few
components one is passing to so applying
regularity passing to subsequences and
obtaining this limit from the regularity
approximations that this use and then we
observe that these use they form a
martingale so we can apply the
martingale convergence theorem to get us
a candidate for the limit and then the
rest is fairly straightforward because
all the steps are good approximations
put them together you prove the limit
any questions all right so you may ask
now we have compactness what is
compactness good form so it may seem
like a somewhat abstract concept so in
the second half of today's lecture I
want to show you how to use this
compactness claim combined with you are
you know the first definition of
compactness that you've seen namely
every open cover contains a finite sub
cover and to use that to prove many
consequences about the space
griffons and some things that we had to
in a work a bit hard at but they turned
out to fall from the compactness
statement okay so let's take a quick
break in the first part of this lecture
we proved that the space of griffons is
compact so now let me show you what we
can you know rebus consequences from the
compactness result so I want to show you
how to apply compactness and prove some
consequences as I mentioned earlier the
compactness result is related to
regularity and in fact many of the
results I'm going to stay you can prove
maybe with some more work using the
regularity lemma but I also want to show
you how to deduce them directly from
compactness in fact will deduce the
regularity lemma from compactness so
these two ideas compactness and
regularity they go hand-in-hand
so first more so as a warm-up but I was
also an interesting result a statement
an interesting statement on its own so
let me prove the following ok so here is
a statement that we can deduce from
compactness so for every epsilon there
exists some number n which depends only
on epsilon such that for every top new
graph um there exists a graph G worth
and vertices such that
the cut distance between G and W is at
most Epsilon so think about whether it
says for every epsilon during some pound
and such that every graph on the graph
on is some real valued function so
taking values between 0 & 1 you can
approximate it in the distance that we
care about by a graph with a bounded
number of vertices this is kind of like
regularity lemma if you are allowed edge
weights on this graph G then it
immediately follows from the weak
regularity lemma that we already proved
and from that weak regularity lemma
which allows you to get some G with edge
weights you can think about how you
might turn into an edge weighted graph
into an on edge way an unweighted graph
so that's that can also be done but I
want to show you a completely different
way of proving this result that follows
from compactness and so I say it's a
warm-up because it's really a warm-up
for the next thing we're going to do and
it shows you this easier example showing
you how to use compactness many so the
idea is I have this compact space I'm
going to cover the space by open sets by
open balls so the open balls are going
to be this B sub epsilon G so for each
graph G I'm going to consider the set of
crayons
that are within epsilon of G so this you
have some topological spaces a metric
space have a point G and I look at its
open ball so that's this is the ball so
I claim that these open balls they form
an open cover the space where is that so
I want to show every point W is covered
so this follows from so this follows
from the claim that every W is the limit
is the limit of some sequence of graphs
so we didn't technically actually prove
this frame so this is I said that if you
take W random graphs you get this okay
so we didn't technically prove that but
okay so it turns out to be true there
are easier ways to establish it as well
by taking one approximations but the
point is that if you use this claim here
you do not get a bound on a number of
vertices it could be that for very
bizarre-looking double use you might
require much more number of vertices a
priori you do not know that it is
bounded as a function of epsilon but now
we we have this open cover
so by compactness of the space of bonds
we can find an open cover
using a finite subset of these graphs
you G 1 2 G K it's a finite subset they
do an open cover and now we let n to be
the least common multiple of all of
these vertex set sizes so all of these
vertices so they can be so all of these
graphs they are within so so for each of
this graph I can replace it by a graph
on exactly n vertices there exist a
graph G Prime exactly n vertices such
that they represent the same point in
the space of graphics devices think
about the representation of a graph on
using from graph if I start with G and I
blow up each vertex into
k vertices then it turns out I mean you
should think about why this is true but
it's hard to see if you draw the picture
so remember this black and white picture
that they're actually they're the same
point they are represented by the same
graph all ok and that's it ok so we
found these these geez
all of them have exactly n vertices such
that they're epsilon open balls form an
open cover of the space of graph on so
every graphing can be approximated by
one of these so you get that from
compactness the statement says for every
epsilon there exists an N so and it's a
function of Epsilon what's the function
this proof doesn't tell anything about
it so this proof gives no information
about the dependence
of M epsilon so it's some senses even
worse than some of the things we've seen
in the earlier discussion on
similarities regularity lemma where they
were tower or wowzer types here there's
no information because it comes from a
compactness statement so you just know
there exists a finite open cover no
bounds okay any questions about this
warm-up application it feels a bit
magical right so you have compactness
and then you have all of these these
consequences so now let me show you how
you can deduce the regularity lemma
itself from compactness in fact in the
proof of the existence in the proof of
compactness we only used weak regularity
and now let me show you how you can use
weak regularity consequences namely
compactness to bootstrap itself to
strong regularity so we saw a version of
strong regularity in the earlier chapter
when we discussed summer least
regularity lemma so let me state it in a
in a somewhat different looking form but
that turns out to be morally equivalent
suppose I have a vector of Epsilon okay
so all of these are positive real
numbers the claim is that there exists
an M which only depends on this vector
such that for every graph on w one can
okay so every graph on w can be written
as following decompose in the following
way we write W as a sum of a structured
part the pseudo-random part and a small
part where the structured part is a step
function with K parts the K is at most M
this cleaned bound M the pseudo-random
part is very has a very small cut norm
so it's cut norm very small even
compared to the number of parts and
finally the small part has L 1 norm
bounded by epsilon 1 so that's the claim
you can always there exists some bound m
in terms of these error parameters so
that you have this decomposition so we
saw some version of this earlier when we
discussed the spectral proof of
regularity lemma and I don't want to go
into details of how these two things are
related but just to comment that
depending on your choice of the epsilon
parameters it relates to some of the
different versions of regularity lemma
that we've seen before so for example if
epsilon K is roughly epsilon some fixed
epsilon over K squared then this is so
this is basically the same as similar
these regularity lemma whereas if all
the case are the same epsilon then this
is roughly the same as the week
regularity lemma
all right how to prove this claim we're
going to use compactness again so first
there always exists an l1 approximation
so that every W has some step function
you associated to it such that the l1
distance between W and you yes at most
epsilon one okay so again this is one of
these more measure theoretic
technicalities I don't want to get into
you but it's not hard to prove so
roughly speaking you have some function
you can approximate it using steps and
now let me but okay so I and asked with
the previous so similar to what we did
just now if you just do that the number
of steps might not be a function of
Epsilon so you might need much more
steps just doing that if your W looks
more pathological so now what we're
going to do is consider the following
function K of W and I define it to be
the minimum K such that there exists a K
step rap on you such that you minus W is
at most Epsilon so among all the step
function approximations pick one that
has the minimum number of steps and call
the number of steps caved up
so now as before we're going to come up
with an open cover of the space of graph
ons so the open cover is going to be
consisting of the cut your balls so
let's consider so this is a ball
centered around W with radius epsilon
sub-k W this is an open cover of the
spacer coughing's
as W ranges over all graphs so I'm
literally looking at every point in the
space and putting an open bar around it
so obviously this is an open cover and
because of compactness there exists a
finite sub cover so there exists a
finite set right curly s of griffons
such that these
balls as a range overcoat w in curly s
they cover the space of griffons okay
now the goal is given the W I want to
approximate it in some way so having a
finite set of things to work with allows
us to do some kind of approximations so
thus for every W graph on there exists a
W Prime in s whose ball in that correct
collection covers the point W such that
W is contained in this in this bowl and
okay so given this w prime because of
you know this this definition over here
so there exists in you with so which is
a K step graph on with K at most the
maximum over all such possible number of
steps
such that W and W Prime they are closed
in cup norm because you have this open
cover and furthermore W prime is close
to a graph on with a small number of
steps okay so suppose we now write W as
u plus W minus W Prime and then plus W
prime minus u we find that this is a
decomposition that we are looking for
because the U so this is the structure
component has K steps where K is less
than this quantity here and that
quantity there is just some function of
Epsilon right at most some function of
the absalons it doesn't depend on a
specific choice of W
the second term this is the
pseudo-random piece because it's cut
norm is small things should be subscript
and finally the third term here is the
small term because it's l1 norm is small
okay so putting them together we get a
regularity lemma so again the proof
gives you no information whatsoever
about the bound M as a function of the
input parameters the epsilon so it turns
out you can use a different method to
get a bounce namely we actually more or
less did this proof when we discussed
regularity lemma the strong regularity
lemma so we did a different proof where
we iterated an energy increment argument
and now gave you some concrete doubts
some balance which iterates on these
epsilon but here's a different proof it
gives you less information but it
elegantly uses this compactness feature
of the space of griffons any questions
okay so we prove compactness now let's
go on to the other two claims the namely
the existence of the limit and the
equivalence is of convergence the
existence of the limit more or less is a
consequence of compactness so you have
this sequence pythons w1 w2 and so on
and the claim is that if this sequence
the sequence of f densities converges
for each F then there exists some limit
W such that all of these sequences f
densities converge to the limit density
okay so that was the claim so nothing
about cut norms in at least as far as
the statement goes well okay from
compactness we know that you can produce
always a sub sequential limit so by
compactness of sequential compactness
there exists some limit point and this W
has the property that for some
subsequence the cut distance from the
sub sequence converges to W so for some
subsequence and knot and I going to
infinity but now by the counting lemma
the sequence of F densities okay so the
counting lemma tells you if you have cut
distance going to zero then the F
density should also go to zero so indeed
that's what we have here so this is so
far just for the subsequence but we
assumed already that entire sequence
converges for every respect to every F
densities so it must be the same limit
and that finishes the proof of proof of
convergence to proof of the existence of
the existence of the limit so we obtain
this limit from compactness next let's
prove the equivalence of convergence and
this one's some more trickier so what
happens here is that we would like to
show that these two notions of
convergence one having to do with f
densities and another having to do with
cut distance that these two notions are
equivalent to each other so the goal
here is to show that this F density
converges it's equivalent to the
statement that W sub n is Cauchy with
respect to the cut distance
or claim one of the directions is easy
which direction is that okay so which
direction is the easy direction so which
way left going left going right okay so
going left okay so I claim that this is
easy because it follows from counting
lemma counting lomilomi the spirit of
the counting lemma least qualitatively
is that if you have to graph outs that
are closing cut distance then they're
closing F densities so if you have Co
sheet with respect to cut distance then
they're Cauchy and hence convergent in F
densities it's the other direction that
will require some work and this one is
actually genuinely tricky so and it's
kind of a it's almost kind of a
miraculous statement that somehow if you
only knew the F densities right so
somebody gives you this very large
sequence of graphs and only tells you
that the triangle density is c4 density
is you know all of these craft densities
they converge somehow from these small
statistics you conclude that the graph
globally look very similar to each other
that's actually if you think about this
is this is an amazing statement okay so
let's see the proof so here is the proof
here in the proof matter here is
somewhat representative of these graph
limit type arguments so it's worth
paying attention to see how this one
goes
by compactness if we're going to set up
by contradiction so if you are if the
sequence is not Cauchy so if the
sequence
is not cozy then there exist limit to
limit points okay so there exist at
least two distinct limit points and call
them U and W and such that so because
you have two separate limit points you
must have that this sequence at least
along a sub sequence that converges to W
converges in F densities to W so
initially this is true along a
subsequence but the left hand side is
convergent so this is true along the
sequence but U is also a limit point so
the same is true for you and therefore
the f density in W must equal to the F
density in top in you for all
[Applause]
okay so we would be done if we can prove
that the F density is the collection of
all these F densities they determine the
graph oh and that's indeed the case so
this is the next claim so when I would
call moment lemma is that if u and W are
fonts such that f densities for all F
then the cart distance between U and W
is equal to 0 some other local
statistics tells you globally that these
two graphs must agree with each other it
so I know why I call it a moment lemma
there is something else which this
should remind you of so there are some
classical results in probability that
tells you if you have two probability
distributions both assume are nice
enough then if they have the same cave
moment for every K there's a first
moment second moment third moment if all
the moments agree that these two
probability distributions should agree
and this is some graphical version of
that so instead of looking at a
probability distribution we're looking
at graph phones which are
two-dimensional these are
two-dimensional objects and this
moment's lemma tells you that it is
two-dimensional and the corresponding
two-dimensional moments namely these F
moments if they agree then the two
graphics must agree so it's the analog
of the probability theory statement
about about moments the proof is
actually somehow tricky so I'm only
going to give you a sketch and the key
here is to consider the W random graph
which we saw last lecture
okay so this is doubly random graph with
K vertices sampled using the graph on W
so a key observation here is that for
every F the probability that the sample
W random graph agrees with F and here
there's a bit of technicality I want
them to agree as labelled graphs so the
vertices of W are a probably labeled one
through K and this K W random graph is
generated with vertices labeled 1
through K they agree with some
probability that is completely
determined by the EF densities yes yes K
is the number of vertices of F and the
specific formula is not so important let
me just write it down but the points if
you know all the F densities then you
have all the information about the
distribution of this W of random graph
and the way you can calculate the actual
probability is via an inclusion
exclusion and the reason we have to do
this inclusion exclusion is just because
this is more like counting induced
subgraphs and this is counting actual
sub graphs so there's an extra step but
the point is if you knew this data the
moments data that you immediately know
the distribution of the W random graphs
so if I have to graph ons that
[Applause]
so if I have two croissants for which I
know that they are f densities agree
then I should be able to conclude that
the corresponding W random graphs also
had the same distribution in particular
this the W random graph and the new
random graph have the same distribution
I'm going to create a variant of the W
random graph which is something called
an H random graph it's kind of like the
W random graph except I forget the very
last step so I only keep a weighted
think of it as so think this I say
waited an edge weighted graph
where are you sample x1 through XK
uniformly between 0 & 1 & I put each
weight between I and J to be W of X I XJ
so the difference between this H version
and the G version is that the G version
is obtained by turning this weight into
an actual edge with that probability but
if I don't do the last step I obtain
this intermediate object so the
following are true and this is where I'm
going to skip the proofs if I look at
the this H random graph and the G random
graph they are very close in cut
distance you can think of this as to
claim that GNP is very close to G in cut
distance okay so they are very closed in
cut distance as K going to infinity with
probability 1
so now gonna do the proof but it's some
kind of a concentration argument and the
second claim is that the H random graph
is actually very close to the original
graph on W as well
this is also little wine in distance as
K goes to infinity so this one is again
not so obvious but it's easier in the
case when W itself is a step function in
which case the produced H is almost the
same as W except the boundaries are
slightly shifted perhaps and so you
first approximate W by a step function
and prove this up to an epsilon
approximation and then the steps go to
infinity so if you have these two claims
so then we see that this one here is
identically distributed as this one here
is identically distributed as kayuu so
it should follow that the corresponding
H random graph for you if you replace
the same inequalities by the new
versions it should also be true so
because these two are the same
distribution if you follow this chain
you're paying that the cut distance
between U and W is equal to zero
I want to close by mentioning it in some
sense so here you have two graphs that
have exactly two graph on them exactly
the same F moments but what if I give
you two graphs which have very similar
moments to each other can you conclude
that the two graphs are close to each
other and that would be some kind of an
inverse counting them and in fact it
does follow as a corollary follows as a
corollary and the statement is that for
every epsilon there exists K and a tub
such that if the two graphs U and W are
such that the F densities do not differ
by more than ETA for every F at most K
vertices then the cut distance between U
and W is at most Epsilon
so the counting lemma tells you if the
cut distance is small then all the F
moments are close to each other and the
inverse or tells you tells you this
converse so tells you this if you have
similar F moments up to a certain point
then this is small you can deduce the
inverse counting lemma from the moments
lemma via a compactness argument similar
to the one that we did in class today
and I want to give you a chance to
practice with the argument so this will
be on homework for the next homework
give you some practice with using these
compactness arguments but you see it's
you know just with the other compactness
statements there it doesn't tell you
anything about the K and the epsilon as
a function of K and theta as a function
of episode
so there are other proofs that gives you
concrete bounds but this proof here is
much simpler if you assume the
corresponding results about compactness
and finally I want to mention that in
the moments lemma in order to deduce
that U and W have the same they're
basically the same graph on we need to
consider F moments for all F so you
might ask could it be the case that we
only need some finite set of F's to
deduce to recover the graph all right is
it the case that you can recover w from
only a finite number of f moments and
this is it's actually a very interesting
problem from which we already saw one
instance namely when we discussed quasi
random graphs we saw that if you know
that the k2 moment is P and also the c4
moment is P fourth then we can deduce
that the graph on must be the constant
graph on P okay so we didn't do it in
this language but that's what the proof
does and likewise you can use this to
deduce a qualitative version where you
have an extra slack and an extra slack
over here so you might ask except for
the constant graph phones are there
other graph falls for what you can
similarly deduce recover this graph on
from just a finite amount of moments
data and such graph owns are known as
finitely forcible
so finally cross forceable graphics
graph owns W such that a finite number
of moments can uniquely recover can
uniquely identify this graph on W and
very interesting questions what is the
set of all finally forcible graphics and
turns out this is not at all obvious and
let me just give you some examples
highly non-trivial that turned out to be
finally forcible for example anything
which is a step graph on it's finally
forcible the half graph on which
corresponds to the limit of a half-court
sequence of half graphs is finally
forcible I mean already I think neither
of these two examples are are easy at
all and this example here could be
generalized where you have any
polynomial curve that's also I think
this has to be polynomial curve it's
also finally forcible but turns out
finally forceful graph phones can get
quite complicated and it's still rather
quite a bit of mystery around them okay
so next time I want to discuss some
inequalities that come out of that you
can state between different F densities
that's all for today